[Música]
emiko vai jantar calma espera jesus
filho agora aí também
[Música]
o videogame e aqui joga videogame
levanta a mão quem aqui os pais falam
para parar jogar videogame levanta a mão
jogos de videogame não costumam por ser
uma boa reputação muitas vezes são
vistos como violentos de ciência e uma
péssima forma de passar o tempo mas isso
não é inteiramente verdade o vídeo game
traz muitos benefícios eles eles são
estimula o crescimento da massa cinzenta
com tom usado pode ser importante para
assistir lógico-matemática concentração
e estabelece uma grande ação social e
quando você joga com pessoas de outros
países você treina seus vídeos
os estímulos ao cérebro faz parte de
trás é a visão as particulares são as
áreas motoras ea parte da frente humor e
emoção
a visão é mais estimulado videogame
também traz outros benefícios deles são
pessoas que já pessoas que jogam games
gestão tomam decisões antes 25% mais
rápidas videogames melhoram a memória o
foco e capacidade multitarefa e idosos
crianças com dislexia melhoram suas
habilidades de leitura jogar videogame
crianças que jogam videogame e melhores
habilidades motoras
o videogame estimular a visão eo reflexo
mas também existem os malefícios que
eles são vício muito tempo na frente até
das telas que levam ao sedentarismo e à
obesidade
alguns jogos de hollande e que causa
distúrbios de atitudes violentas nas
crianças e alguns jogos que dirigem as
forças musculares que causam dores como
os pais devem usar uso ele deve ensinar
à criança que o videogame uma
descontração deles é uma coisa mais
importante para fazer no dia ele o
desenho era faixa etária do jogo no
verso da capa eles também devem testar o
jogo antes de disponibilizarem a criança
para verificar acesso recentemente que
ela quer ajudar
aqui vão algumas dicas videogame tem
recompensas muito prazerosas mas não
deixam de sair fazer esporte brincar com
os amigos mas nunca
os jogos são virtuais você nunca deve
trazê los para o mundo em redor real
obrigada
[Aplausos]
[Música]